We tampered with the fabric of reality
what's happening starting to
come through and i can't stop him
I can't believe i'm in the
saints i'm saying neither can i
hi everyone i am tom holland you might recognize
me as your friendly neighborhood spider-man and
i am here to tell you that spidey's back for
an all-new adventure in spider-man no way home
i know people say this a lot but i mean it
when i say that you're gonna see things in
this movie that you've never ever seen
before i'm talking about pumpkin bombs
sandstorm the multiverse which okay you
might have seen them before but i promise
not like this and not together also peter parker
is finally heading off to college and the word is
out so yeah everyone knows that he is spider-man
so throw your fan theories out the window they're
probably not true or are they and get ready to see
one of the most ambitious films we've ever made an
incredible story with lots of heart laughter high
flying action mind-blowing effects and some insane
villains no way home is the culmination of
the homecoming trilogy and the start of a
multiverse of possibilities now i have the
honour of introducing some legends please
enjoy this exclusive panel with my dear friends
alfred molina william defoe and jamie foxx
Welcome back everyone this is my new spider-man
no way home trailer video there's a bunch of new
footage and easter eggs so we'll break it all
down we're doing a giveaway for imax tickets
for the movie all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and just leave your favorite
moment from the trailer on the video i love how
during that clip tom holland is winking at all
the fan theories like all your fan theories
are probably wrong but maybe they're not
andrew garfield was also doing kind of the same
thing recently when people were trying to get him
to talk about the movie it's andrew garfield
playing spider-man again oh you almost got me
no no no i'm not i'm not i'm not crying out loud
but i'm excited to see what they're going to do
with the next movie because i i just love them
thankfully we won't have to wait that long to
actually get some concrete answers literally next
week the movie is coming out but just starting
with this new footage first we get more of the
spider-man vs doctor strange fight scene in the
mirror universe and it gets way crazier than you
ever thought like huge upgrade to all the mirror
universe fighting in the first doctor strange
movie with spider-man trying to joint doctor
strange's box that he's using to try and trap the
sinister six villains and send them back to their
original universes it's hard to tell where this
fight scene actually starts like does it start
with him lassoing him with the crimson bands
of sidorak through the portals here yoinking
him down to the ground where he separates him
into the astral form like the ancient one did
to him and then to the hulk during avengers end
game or does the chase scene start here inside
the sanctum like this small fight scene with
him yoinking the box then running and doctor
strange is opening a portal to the mirror universe
underneath him so that when he tries to web sling
from the sanctum to another building he just hits
dead air and falls into the mirror universe where
you get all these scenes of new york city just
going bonkers upside down folding in on itself
it's a very clever way to try and trap someone
especially someone like spider-man or to keep them
from running away because no matter how fast
he runs or webb slings away eventually space
just folds back in on himself and he'll be web
slinging right back to doctor strange but i love
the way that he crashes through dimensions
here like he's shattering through a mirror
this is going to look amazing in a theater you
also notice how dr strange's portals are affected
by the mirror universe multiplying to infinity so
doctor strange didn't open up infinity portals he
just opened one portal in the mirror universe is
doing its thing like if you had a clip that was
high res enough you could zoom and enhance forever
and there would just be more and more portals
inside each of these portals to infinity then
there's a new clip of ned leeds and mj coming into
the sanctum much to dr strange's chagrin this is
probably after spider-man agrees to help him and
he says he's going to need some more help to catch
the sinister six villains and then either doctor
strange portals both of them here or spider-man
goes and gets them the old-fashioned way this is
probably happening right before that scooby-doo
scene with doctor strange yelling at all of them
there are others out there we need to send them
back so scooby doo this crap you know all this
is kind of your mess i know a couple of magic
words myself starting with the word please please
scooby-doo this crap you have to appreciate doctor
strange tolerating them here too i can't believe
i'm in the sanctum neither can i like he would
saw his own arm off if he thought that it would
get them out of here and fix this faster there
was another funny line of dialogue that he had
where he said something like this is why i
didn't have kids because he absolutely hates
the idea of teenagers and spider-man the way
he's trying to fight him so hard on this box
then in the new villains trailer that i put at the
beginning of this they did the special villains
panel where willem dafoe alfred molina jamie foxx
explained what's going on with their characters
during the movie and why they came back we get
more new footage of green goblin that shows what
he actually looks like later in the movie once
he loses the goblin helmet and he's wearing a
very comic book accurate purple shroud and pouch
with a strap to hold all his gears pumpkin bombs
so in this scene just overall he looks like a very
comic book accurate version of the character but
if it wasn't clear he is the only version of green
goblin in the movie there's not multiple goblins
it's the same version when he has the mask and
the full armor on i think it's just implied by
this new footage that at some point during one of
their early battles in the movie his goblin armor
gets damaged and that's why he looks this way
later in the movie the way willem dafoe described
him is that he was kind of the same thing from the
tobey maguire spider-man movie mostly with just a
few minor differences i got speared pretty good
uh in the first film uh but i thought okay they
can figure out a way to bring me back and when we
went deeper into it i liked the idea that i was
returning to something that was same but different
it's a return to something i did before with that
kind of history but the spin there's a spin on it
what he means when he's talking about a little bit
different is just the new version of the costume i
also love that alfred molina joked the main reason
why he came back was money and that was just
a joke that wasn't clear just him and the boys
joshing around trying to kill them some spider-man
alfred ah for me it's just about the money
oddly enough willem and i were kind of joshing the
other day about how 20 years since his green first
green goblin 17 years since my first time as doc
ock jamie foxx said that he was excited to come
back mostly because they promised him he would be
so much cooler in this movie and it does look like
he is way cooler way more comic book accurate big
big upgrade from what they did with his character
during andrew garfield's amazing spider-man 2.
the other really cool thing that tom holland just
revealed is that he personally knows who bought
the avengers tower in the mcu we've all had our
fantastic four theories since spider-man far from
home came out i've already done several videos
about that about all these fantastic four easter
eggs that happen in this scene when they show you
the new avengers tower the marvel producers
recently said that they weren't gonna reveal
that information who actually bought the tower
for a little while but tom holland said right
now he already knows so you all know the drill
now we just play the waiting game to see how long
it will take him to leak the information
during an interview so i uh hello hello
he also confirmed that peter parker is trying to
get into college during the events of this movie
i did a video last week talking about that about
how during the movie he's trying to get into mit
because that's where iron man went to college when
he was a teenager riri williams also currently
goes there during the events of black panther 2
but i believe that the events of black panther 2
take place after spider-man no way home that movie
is not coming out till next year but you see shuri
and okoye come to peep on riri williams because
of the whole armor plot they're basically doing
a version of her origin story from the comics mit
was also the place where iron man was showing off
his barf technology during captain america
civil war and also later we found out during
spider-man far from home where mysterio was off
stage watching the presentation getting really
pissed off that he named his technology barf so
mit is just a really big location inside the mcu
but my early theory is actually that he won't
get into mit i'm hoping that he doesn't and
instead either winds up going to empire state
in new york city like he did during the comics
and the tobey maguire spider-man movies or
big twists big long shot here he goes to the
future foundation and it's the future foundation
that bought the avengers tower like it becomes
the new baxter building in the mcu one of the cool
details here in this scene during spider-man far
from home post-credit scene is that the location
where they're standing here on the street corner
right in front of the new avengers tower the
redesigned avengers tower is that in new york
city it's actually really close to the location of
where the comic book baxter building was also john
watts the director of spider-man no way home and
all the solo spider-man movies in the mcu so far
is directing the new marvel fantastic four movie
so it just seems like there's gonna be some sort
of soft crossover between the spider-man franchise
the future tom hall and trilogy movies that he's
doing in the future fantastic four movies at some
point the fantastic four also crossed over in
amazing spider-man number one the very first
issue of his solo title after amazing fantasy
there's a bunch of big spider-man videos that i'll
be posting in the next week or so but i'll wait
till the movie actually comes out next week to
do my full post credit scene video full breakdown
easter eggs for the movie there'll be so much to
talk about there's so much going on in this movie
i'm not i'm not i'm not crying out loud i will
be posting a review of the movie next week too
i believe that marvel is letting us post our
reviews on monday so if i do get a chance to see
the movie early i will try to post a non-spoilery
review earlier in the week my full hawkeye episode
4 video will post next on wednesday just like
normal make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss anything there's a
bunch of big daredevil and kingpin stuff going on
and elena belova so everyone click here for
all my spider-man no way home trailer videos
and easter eggs and click here for my brand new
spider-man across the spiderverse trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!